can tell us what happened what did you
see what did you hear
well we were just stopped by the
swimming pool actually just obviously a
holiday I'm a bit of sunbathe and then
all of a sudden we were told or we sort
of saw everybody sort of get up there's
probably two 300 people out there
sunbathing everybody started running
towards the hotel and the beach is
probably situated about two three
minutes walk from the hotel people came
up that alley as well everybody got into
the hotel we were towards the end of
everything and on our way about halfway
between the pool and a hotel we had
quite a large explosion and sorry we
just Christ we've just had an email from
the hotel if David and feel able please
other stuff and this people running
obviously around the hotel no one's
really been told what to do where are
you now David are you in your hotel room
we're in our hotel room we have been for
about 20 minutes so far we've done the
obvious stuff you know shows show the
balcony door closed again we keep hear
hearing but we don't know you see what's
going on no one's really telling us
exactly what's going on okay so you were
sunbathing by the pool and you heard a
loud explosion what happened then did
you see people did you see attackers or
just to exposure at all obviously we
have quicker when we heard that and we
heard people people saying that there
was there was guns on the beach and
people were shooting on the beach I
guess to the left of where where our
hotel beach is so yeah honestly I mean I
don't know what's going on in terms of
no one's actually told us I went to
reception that said you know Kate can
you can he let us know what's happening
and they were like the police have been
I've told us to get everybody inside
but obviously been been in a hotel room
we could we can't really do much more
can you see anything from your balcony
can you see any police presence anything
that's going on out
no one's outside about five minutes ago
I saw some people sort of running
towards there's people on the roof not I
don't think they're I think
representative from the hotel is on top
of the roof and have you seen anybody
been injured that you're aware of David
have you have you seen any anything like
that no no no one's injured I can I can
see I think people just just want to
know what's going on and and that email
from the hotel did he give you any
information whatsoever or was it just
simply cases stay in your room I don't
know I just I just get a phone abscess
on my girlfriend's phone this was from
notices there was one from the hotel so
this is from one of the news editors at
Sky we I had my GoPro camera on at the
time so you feel some of what was
happening well yeah and we didn't see
anything but you your audio wise your
head or bust without a doubt I would
have thought and those things I try and
try and get a little bit to you guys
obviously and just in terms of how long
have you been there David have you been
there a few days already yeah we arrived
on Wednesday night and I think will be
yeah probably heading home pretty soon
yeah David I don't blame you but just in
terms of since you've been there
what has security been like if you felt
threatened at all has there been any
heightened security around your hotel
what's been the atmosphere like in the
build-up to this or has just come out of
the blue
yeah no completely out of blue I mean I
I you know we knew that there had been
something that happened a few months ago
with the museum and we knew it wasn't
you know a hundred percent safe
afterworlds are never safe at the moment
so we didn't feel that any anything was
heightened in terms of police presence I
went when we came we literally got off
the plane go on some coaches came to the
hotel and apart from the normal
hotel security you would have anywhere I
would say there's been any additional
additional security at all but of course
the people on the beach the people who
would be the most shaken up because they
will have seen something and I got
someone
in the hole that said you know that they
were on the beach at the time sir and
what did they say that they'd seen days
they saw so song with a gun on the beach
and people running saying get off the
beach get off the beach